when learning a lead for the
first time it's hard to know which
way to go there are so many popular
methods and learning pathways
that most people
just pick the first method
they come across and go with that one
this works well for a  time
but most people soon
discover that the method they are using
this more has become boring too
stressful or just too
abstract and you can't help them use
the language they are
learning efficiently let's say
and if there was a better way what would happen
if you could find a tried
and tested method that is well organized and
structured according to the
main language skills
able to help you memorize words
sentences easily and naturally able
to develop your ability to think
directly in your target language
built on a foundation  of
corrections without stress and fun and
rewarding
fortunately there is no need to
wonder in this video I will share
with you some of the
fundamental concepts of this method and do not
forget to stay tuned until the end
because I have a surprise for you that you do not
want to miss hello I am never
lampariello I am a language coach who
speaks  14 languages including Spanish and in this
hannel he helps people to learn
foreign languages effic
and quickly this video
s the second part of a series on h
w to start learning a new languag
by now I gu
ss you have seen the first video
of the  series and you've picked
a very good beginner resource
based on the recommendations
I made there but if you haven't seen
this video yet check it out now I've
included a link in the description of
this video
once you have your
beginner resource handy  you can start
working on the one activity that will be
the backbone of all your
future learning success.  language learning
developing skills
this is an important detail that
is often overlooked
language learning is first and foremost about
acquiring skills these are learning
to read write speak and listen along
with all the myriad sub-
skills that any
competent language speaker has  in your
toolbox in traditional classrooms
minute skill development
is overlooked in favor of facts
made in the form of conjugation tables
word lists
grammar explanations verb tense names
etc all of those things are
related to plain language  but it is
important to realize that knowing
these things has nothing to do with
speaking and using a language effectively,
for example, do you ever consult a
table of verbs to learn your mother
tongue, I don't think so, so my method the
method of which  i'll talk to you today don't
waste your time with those things
instead i'll show you how  o use
translation to develop a
strong foundation of authentic language skills
the same skills that
native speakers of your
target language your target language use every
day
let's see them
step 1 thoroughly understand the
content in part 1 of this series
I talked extensively about the importance
of bilingual texts and in
particular bilingual dialogues with
audio files and you took my advice the resource
you chose contains many of these
dialogues that you will now use to
start learning the language you are
learning in this first step the
objective  is to learn how to take these
beginner dialogues that must
come in both your native and
target languages and use them to devel
p a deep understanding of what
he t
rget language version of the dialogue actually means as a
eginner the first
few  skills you need to
develop are listening and reading this way.
This way you will be able to interpret the sounds and
decipher the written language that is used
to represent these sounds
hopefully your bilingual dialogues
should have everything you need
to start listening and quickly
once you feel comfortable following
the text and audio you can develop
a deeper understanding  dialogue
in multiple ways read the text and listen to
the audio at the same time read the text
only in your target language without audio
read the text only in your native language
read the text aloud in your
target language compare versions of the
dialogue in the target language in your
target language and in the native language and use
the accompanying grammatical notes to
clarify any details that you have not
been able to understand completing these
activities will help you to
progressively gain a
deeper and deeper understanding of what
anything really means  dialogue in your
textbook at this stage focus
solely on understanding what
the dialogue means don't worry
about translation or
memorization yet all this will come later
step number 2 translate the text into your
native language now that you understand what
the target language version of your language is supposed to mean
dialogue let's complete
our first translation step take
the target language text and
translate it into your native language since
your chosen beginner resource
probably already comes with
a native language translation of the dialogue
you may be
curious about  why this is necessary the
answer is personalization
your brain is more likely to memorize
information that it feels is important and
meaningful to you right out of your
textbook the dialogue you've
been working on
probably doesn't have much
personal relevance because the truth is someone
more wrote the dialogue because it is not
something that is exclusive to you or your
circumstances  s by taking the dialogue in the
target language and using what you
have learned so far to
translate that dialogue into your own
words you are doing two things
you are creating a more personal and
more memorable unique version of the dialogue by paying more
attention to the content to the structure
of the dialogue  original dialogue so that you can
faithfully translate it into your own language
together these two steps will help
further solidify your knowledge of the
dialogue and make it much easier to
memorize the words and phrases they
contain
at this point it is important to consider
how to perform this translation and where  you
will save it for most
people i recommend writing the
translation by hand in a
language notebook dedicated exclusively for
this or writing the translation and
saving it in your software like google
docs knowshon or evernote i personally
enjoy writing my translations in
a google doc write me
allows you to complete the process
fairly quickly  and doing it in
word processing software
allows me to easily move and reformat things
step number 3
translate the text back into your target language
now for the final step you're going to take your
custom native language version
of the original dialog and go back to
translate it into the target language this is
the most powerful step in the whole process
as it provides a number of
key benefits tests
your brain's ability to remember what
you learned in the previous two
steps tests your ability to form
sentences and  sentences in your
target language or target language forces you to think
directly in your target language
so that your final sentences
convey the correct
meaning so where do we start first we
actually start waiting once
you have completed the
native language translation in  the last step is better to
wait 24-48 hours before
translating the dialog back to
your target language  target language why
you should wait because waiting helps
you forget and why you should forget
because information that is forgotten and
then remembered will create stronger imprints
than information that is
never forgotten traditional schooling
teaches us that forgetting is
a bad thing  but research in
neuroscience has shown that forgetting
plays a fundamental role in
memorization I repeat if we forget something and
then we remember what we have forgotten
we will remember it better in the future
if you wait 1 or 2 days to complete your
second translation step you will be
taking advantage of this  important neural mechanism
once you're ready to re-
translate here's what to watch out for
translate sentence by sentence
first read the full version of each
sentence in your native language and then
try to convey the meaning of
this sentence to your target language avoid
translate word for word if
possible if you discover that you have forgotten
one  word or phrase try to rack your
brain for three or ten seconds and
try to remember it if you still can't
remember it after that time leave a
blank in your translation and
look it up later once you
look it up those forgotten words and phrases will
be remembered  more strongly in the
future when you have finished this back
translation step to the best of
your ability you can compare your new version
in the target language with the
original version in your course book this step
provides the
stress free feedback I mentioned
earlier as  helps you look at
the types of the types of mistakes they
make in the language as well as the types
of things that you are likely to forget
and remember
so there you have it those are the three
key steps that will help you learn
any language through  the
translation let's recap first you have
to understand all the content from top to bottom
second translate the text into your
native language  o third and last
translate the text back into your target language
these steps are a summary of the method
I used to learn 10 of the 14
languages I speak today if you use them and d
it often you will quickly begin to re
d understand and think in your
target language even as a beginner if
you want to learn more about
this method including among other things the
powerful learning plan that will
help you alternate those
activities consistently and efficiently take a
look at the description box
below I have provided a link to  my
new online course that will teach you
everything you need to know about how to put
my bidirectional translation to work
for you so that you too can
learn any
and the course has been translated also in
spanish with subtitles and pdf without
material as always thanks for watching me
and  happy learning
[Music]